hello everybody and welcome to part 9
let's play nightmare house - all right
we left off with us going through some
sort of parking garage why does this guy
have the only flashlight besides me one
of the equip why do I have to go screw
you guys you guys are jerks
alright fine I'll go up so you can all
play house right here I'll get out of my
way make me go up there
screw you all right there we go okay got
a pallet maybe I can use that um get
this thing maybe Oh give me Oh No ah
damn it
yep that okay
all right
yeah del button squid gonna do to do and
then get on it
alright go ok this vent up here ok
BAM oh boy the dark vent again well I
guess I'm gonna go crazy a little more I
bet in the end I'm gonna kill you guys
guys still ok ok oh no oh no what the
hell
Oh what the what the hell what the hell
what the hell please let that be is just
some loser loser loser
Oh No Oh what the [ __ ] Oh No Oh tell me
they're not dead oh no oh no no no no no
no oh I don't want to be alone I want to
be alone I don't want to be alone please
let me be alive oh thank you back oh man
sorry to miss you oh wow ok huh oh man
oh yeah get that get that get it get it
I always wanted to do this get it
yep oh yeah after you isn't that like
SWAT training breach bang and clear come
on seriously design this place and what
yeah exactly
Oh
oh this is so bad
ah oh no oh yeah get the Duke music
going oh now I feel like a badass Oh
bring it on I'm so ready
I'm so ready die guys freaky freaky
Buster oh yeah Oh bring it on bring it
on bring it on
oh you got nothing oh yeah I'm so
channeling dude guy right now I'll bring
it on damn it let's go guys come on
party's over Oh or has a party just
begun oh yeah Oh blood everywhere
Oh get off of here from Maryland go get
it hot in here you got nothing ah oh I
don't even need a flashlight told you
yeah oh yeah more ammo more ammo for
long
Wow nice jump guy oh hello
Oh reloading butter butter butter butter
oh yeah oh oh you're not even sherry
anymore where the other time hello hello
Oh Tabu Bangi get ready for some
revolving action boom I'll bring it
bring bah boom Oh
finish that guy off for me thank you
waste my 357 5
yeah go go where I'll go there okay I
will
all right oh ah it was nothing
I'll kill them all just as soon as we
get out of there
how convenient all right I'll get me out
of here I'm so ready to leave so ready
oh man
oh no no everyone still here you okay
man headache oh I had that too and i
toughed it out I didn't was complain
stop bitching about it oh yeah you did
you slow that door yeah there we go I'll
lead the way
thank you I will I don't know
oh truck can we get this can we use this
truth to get out of here please tell me
yeah nope nope no don't stay with him
until he gets better yes sir oh wait
who's going with me who's going with me
okay oh okay good you're not stupid
enough to stay by yourself and you can't
just force it open you need to do some
wild oh yeah some love okay what the
hell man you're blowing doors treating
them with love you got something with
doors man
why'd you send me with a Gazette skating
ever since he found out he's leaving the
source in a few weeks
uh-huh why cuz he's going insane come on
guy the second try to keep you alive
even though you're probably gonna die
and they're gonna go what happened
there's Jamie John don't get him out
here somewhere oh come in the room don't
just stand there
cuz if you stand that the doors gonna
close in your girl no huh loading bay
gate now opening please stand clear
okay alright jackpot yeah let's go
okay let's get back I don't like being
alone with you here oh come on what's
wrong with me
what the hell is he doing get control of
yourself yeah
stop that noise
okay what in the world is he talking
about yeah man um duh man we gotta do
something
mama shoot you in the head it's just
getting worse and worse
you're not taking us out you're leading
us straight in now yourself right now
hold on guy get ready we might have to
react this turns violent uh-huh I'm
ready it's all your fault it's all your
for you son of a [ __ ] I'll do it what
the you don't want to do this this isn't
looking good
get ready to [ __ ] I'm ready watch the
fires of hell Oh nope nope I'm gonna
happen oh [ __ ] ha ha oh sorry so sorry
about that okay
Oh what the hell what are you talking
about hello there good dude that was the
stupidest thing ever
obviously the target is more powerful
than we thought we need to get out of
here before things get any worse oh man
just cuz I have quicker reaction from
you they're ready ready to kill the
crazies
all right whatever whatever goddamn oh
come on
Ausmus no head gone Oh miss boom bang Oh
axe stand up to this ahead Splosion
lunch bladder splatter hey some light
oh are they not for long buh buh buh buh
oh yeah myleeza Sambi Oh more torso
zombies
all right we're down to two guys oh yeah
huge yeah it was a good job you all
should be so thankful that I'm here for
you in your time of need even though I'm
probably gonna be the next one to go
crazy man oh thank you for opening that
door for me and see all these days ha ha
yeah oh yeah did all right I gotta cut
it here thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you guys in part
10 10 question mark 10 of let's play
nightmare house - bye bye